il n'y a jamais eu une seconde je n'ai pas
peur le snowboard à tout moment est
absolument magnifiquement terrifiant et
c'est ce qui le rend si
merveilleux  Au début de la saison,
dès que la saison de snowboard a
commencé, cela n'avait pas vraiment d'importance, car
alors tout avait du sens, c'est un peu
magique, vous vous tenez sur quelque chose et vous
volez dans l'espace
.  Je suis en apesanteur, c'est ce qui se
rapproche le plus de l'
existence du snowboard et du ski
avant tout. Je pense que beaucoup de
gens font du snowboard et du ski bien au-delà du
temps où ils s'intéressent au snowboard
et au ski, mais ils continuent à le faire.  donc
parce qu'ils ont un sens de l'expérience partagée d'
une communauté mais quand vous
vous retirez de cela, vous vous retirez
de tout et vous vous retrouvez
un peu seul, je me sens
parfois seul ou  Ici, c'est pour toujours 21
ici, nous passons certainement beaucoup de temps à
nous divertir après la tombée de la nuit de la manière la
plus terrible possible, cela va
de pair vous sortez de la montagne et
vous êtes sur un high et les gens veulent ils
ne veulent pas  perdez ce sentiment, alors vous le
faites la nuit, puis vous vous réveillez
le matin et vous recommencez et pour
certaines personnes, vous ne vous
réveillez plus et vous continuez
à sortir la nuit et cela devient votre votre
motivation pour  pour être ici
[Musique]
ouais alors mon ami surtout vois que
tu es plus du genre donc je vois une
soirée karaoké pendant que tu connais le vin mercredi
parce que je suis un playboy surtout dans une
nuit tachée chérie du
micro ouvert KC d'Ozzy Yul Brynner ouais alors  laissez
Sanjeev ing n'obtenez pas un singe vu je
suppose que c'était fini Alfred
Sunday Funday K sur une paire de
superscalaire je propose moniece il a je
viens je gardais l'ensemble K Lalaji
LaShawn est Louisa spycam Palazzo à
long terme aussi peur averti  famille qui
n'est pas mieux dans  l'amour avec le castor,
ils sont venus Jessie ventouse L'
agence John Townsend a déclaré à Las Vegas que vous pouvez
ajouter un Phi T municipal supplémentaire car
razandrich il est un BF un présomptif comme d'
accord et Keaton comme le
monsieur de la fête merci super loterie
la logistique impliquée était à peu près
Leslie dit  oui je me souviens que ma mère s'est
battue une seconde juste à la télévision n'importe quel
tableau d'évaluation psychologique une clé de fans donnée k juste
un homme saute de notre fitc c'est juste
plus petit
[Musique]
ce qui signifie l'expérience de l'avenue Banff et
par l'avenue Banff je veux dire la rue principale
et la carte car vous savez que les touristes
vont être les plus présents la plupart des gens
vivent ici je ne pense pas avoir traversé l'
avenue Banff en plein jour en dix
ans je ne pense honnêtement pas
qu'après avoir vécu ici pendant un certain temps  tu vois
plus les montagnes je ne sais pas de quoi
il s'agit mais je ne peux pas je ne peux pas les
peindre je ne peux pas je ne peux pas vraiment
saisir ce qu'elles te font
et c'est tellement insaisissable que peut-être  c'est
ce que je suis toujours là j'essaie toujours de
pour comprendre exactement ce que c'est que de
vivre à l'ombre de ces montagnes
[Musique]
toi